good morning Hank it's Tuesday October
10th 2017 and I'm sitting on a hotel
floor in New York City which can only
mean one thing my new book Turtles all
the way down is out now at least in the
US the UK Ireland Australia New Zealand
in several other countries first things
first if you've already read the book
thank you I hope that you liked it also
please do not spoil it for other people
okay so I've created a spoiler if except
reddit hold on that's the elevator
oh man it's mieze all the way down can't
decide if I should wear a suit look who
I picked up it's a Hank hello right but
to return to the topic at hand I have
created a spoiler if Excel reddit for
Turtles all the way down were people who
have read the book can go and discuss it
with each other and also ask questions
of me directly there's a link in the
doobly-doo below we have to go to our
rehearsal now we're about to go on stage
before our rehearsal show and I'm super
stressed out and Hanks just like chillin
of course that's what you're doing hey
thanks for wearing my face on your torso
by the way couple other things I signed
over 200,000 copies of the US edition of
turtles all the way down so hopefully
you won't have trouble finding an
autographed one unless you live outside
of the US or Canada in which case I'm
sorry
hello be from the future here because me
from the past forgot to tell you about
the second thing which is that I wanted
to share some of the reviews the book
has gotten today they've all been really
generous The Wall Street Journal called
it tender wise and hopeful the New York
Times called it a wrenching and
revelatory novel it got starred reviews
from book lists and slj and The Guardian
said it might be a new modern classic
which is a bit much but you know what
I'll take it all right back to the past
which is in your present all right we
just did our first warm-up show Hank how
did it go bad no we went all right okay
you could kind of tell that we'd never
rehearsed well this was a rehearsal and
I was somewhat surprised when I found
out there were gonna be 150 people there
they were very nice though we're very
nice especially Olivia who told me all
the words to my songs
Hank forgot the words to every single
one of his songs but fortunately there
was a young woman named Olivia in the
front row who had all of Hanks songs
memorized so everything worked out
better than expected I wouldn't actually
say better than expected but I would say
differently from expected it worked out
just fine this is the final version of
the book that it is what is it look eyes
with the dust cover off oh there's a
secret there's a secret there's a secret
yeah I'm not gonna show you it's pretty
cool right that's great yeah that was
designed by people in nerdfighteria why
didn't
tell me about that we could have made
merch from it oh my god we have merch
from it it's called Turtles all the way
down it's available in bookstores
everywhere okay I'm gonna ask you some
questions from our audience that we
didn't get to answer during the show if
2016 was a giant dumpster fire
what is a visual representation of 2017
is it just like what's left after a
dumpster fire 2017 the year of burnt
garbage do you listen to music while
you're writing your books this will
surprise your Hank but I do only the
mountain goats how does it feel to have
Hank be a published author I'm so
psyched I'm so happy I'm so proud of
Hank John yes if I yeah it was cast in a
movie adaptation of your book who would
I play I mean that seems unlikely on a
lot of levels can I be the tuatara
that's actually not a bad call show me
your best to ATAR up I just got a neck
cramp that's the most disturbing things
like efforts I'm gonna put up a real
tuatara let's go back to back is it a
good impression or not you be the judge
but it has to have like some lines it
definitely does not have lines the whole
point of the tuatara is that it is a
cold razor and Tudor Hey
oh man I'm a living fossil again Turtles
all the way down is out now and you can
go to the subreddit there is a link
below if you want to talk about spoilers
please don't talk about them in comments
thank you thank you for reading dftba
Hank I will continue to see you right
now